[Music]
all right cool
my name is Ben Chang I'm a product
manager on cloud storage I have with me
today man vinda who is responsible for
our technology partners and a special
guest Ralph from Veritas so today we'll
talk about building cloud storage that
spans on-prem to the cloud I know we use
the word hybrid here and knowing means
certain things to certain people but
just put it aside so it's kind of like
hey the zombies are coming right so does
zettabyte ash is coming the 44
zettabytes probably familiar to some of
you I think cisco commissioned a study a
few years ago where they focused
forecasted about 44 zettabytes by 2020
so we have a new number today's hung an
80s data bytes by 2025 so the question
really is that how can we manage storage
right how can we hole that much data can
we manage and store the data in the
traditional way in your data center even
with compression deduplication and so on
we are still talking about a lot of data
all right so question then is like okay
if we want to use it store this data in
the traditional way to be going and
spending spree and you know buy all the
storage hardware we can get if that's
your plan let me know in a buy shares in
HP and Dell and so on so why not
leverage cloud storage essentially when
you leverage cloud storage you know
Google will take on the owners of
dealing with capital costs we will deal
with the operations and all that so
essentially you are able to store more
data more quickly right so you are
essentially when your amount of your
copies of data increases if you want to
handle and manage that all by yourself
you're basically raising against that
increase so Google we can do that much
better than you because we cannot
leverage it across
of different customers across
internalization so on going hybrid also
helps reduce complexity because you know
when as you buy more Hardware you're
talking about multiple platforms
different than this different software
and all that worse we cloud essentially
with Google for example it's one single
platform the single set of API single
set of tools a single vendor to yell at
essentially and and this is a pitch
right for Google Cloud storage I mean
the key was there are robust seamless
and also simplicity and low cost okay I
forgot
let's save questions to the end we have
lots of slides so they will help us get
through things and this is our storage
portfolio we have basically two storage
tiers or classes for life or frequently
accessed data and two storage classes
for infrequently or called infrequently
access or cold data so there's multi
regional regional multi-regional
essentially means that we are going to
sort the data across multiple data
centers in continental locations by the
US India or a pack regional would mean
that you store the data in the set of
data centers that in the East Coast US
or west coast and so on and depending on
your use cases how frequently want to
access the data whether your consumers
are continent white or regional you may
want to sort the data differently right
multi-regional versus regional and then
also depending on your frequency of
access you can decide the soil and then
your line in code line more details here
you know we talked about pricing and so
on I think the keys the key things to
note here is the redundancy right we're
going talk about jury Nancy so
multi-regional we are talking about more
in two regions two regions or more
separated by at least hundred miles
apart
we should own airline coline company in
the region
there's performance as well which is
interesting right so we talked about
first byte V latency right so there's
very different from a lot of our
competitors where the coldest T of
storage
has an excess penalty right where if you
want access the data you have to wait
three to five hours I think that's fine
if you're used to you know retrieving
data from paper but for a lot of use
cases you want to get the data as
quickly as possible because you're going
to do a request and then wait right so
the data is available like within
milliseconds is essentially the same
platform technically so you don't have
to kind of like worry that okay I store
my data in code here and therefore I
have to wait hours and I cannot achieve
the performance that I need to gather
data as quickly as possible the other
thing that that is very unique to us is
a consistent API so across the different
tiers is essentially one API a single
set of tooling if you're writing your
own tools you don't have to worry about
all my data as a co line I need to
access it differently versus everything
else here's a slide about our storage
location so our data centers the square
boxes are where we have data centers
today the blue boxes are where we are
planning to open data centers right so
in in multiple regions increasing number
of regions as so we know for example
customers may want to keep their data
within a Geo locality or in a region or
a country for whatever reason so we're
opening all these mini data centers the
yellow dots are our points of presence
so it is basically measuring the
distance between where you are your data
center your company to the nearest point
of presence so that kind of reduces the
error latency and that's very unique to
Google because we have a lot more points
of presence and competitors a lot more
network here we basically highlight the
different kind of multivision
multi-regional pockets so us you and
Asia
here we want to highlight you know the
cause of cloud storage is always going
down right you know we kind of highlight
that from 2011 right when it was like
slightly less than point one seventy
five dollars I believe now is all the
weight
you know the lowest year is 0.7 cents a
gigabyte month and as we optimize the
infrastructure we'll pass on the cost
savings to our customers all right so
question how do I start using cloud
storage in hybrid so I'm gonna hand over
to a man vendor who would go into a lot
of the details can you guys hear me
awesome thanks Ben
so now this session is about hybrid
storage scenarios but as Ben was talking
about our product portfolio I just
noticed that all of our products are in
the cloud Ben and I don't talk to that
often so that's why I just noticed that
but but the point is that is why it's so
critical for us to work with partners
who either manage data on Prem or help
move that data between on Prem and the
cloud and as we go through the slides
I'll talk about some of these partners
and how they can help us solve these use
cases all right so what are these hybrid
scenarios so we thought we will pick
three of the most common scenarios or
three very common scenarios that we see
our customers asking us about and walk
through some of the challenges they're
facing how we're solving them what
partners are helping solve those and we
just go into details of those so the
first one is what we're calling bursting
but there's lots of different names but
essentially the idea is you have your
storage on Prem your data which has a
lot of gravity is sitting on Prem but
you want to use the cloud for compute
write with transient compute cyclically
compute jobs bad jobs any bursty kind of
workloads so we'll talk about that the
second is your classical set of use
cases around backup and disaster
recovery and application continuity and
those kind of things as we will talk
about those in today's today's session
we'll go deep into backup and when talk
about different trade-offs and and those
things and then finally we were hearing
more and more of our customers want to
actively archive their primary storage
to the cloud expand the storage that
they have and then save money in the
process so they want to you
cold hearing to the cloud so we'll talk
about that all right
so bursting so as I mentioned we have a
lot of customers who for various reasons
want to keep the data on Prem
whether that's compliance reasons its
internal company policies but it's
really cost effective to leverage
compute in the cloud and especially
high-performance computer jobs example
would be a hedge fund that has a lot of
transaction data but they want to run
Monte Carlo simulations in the cloud
understand their risk profile and that's
a classical use case of when you could
burst your computer into the cloud we
also see a lot of M&E Studios doing
rendering transcoding those kind of
compute jobs in the cloud so the key
thing here is how do you move that data
close to the compute instance in the
cloud and then move it to wherever you
want after that and we work with
partners in those cases a great example
of a top partner for us is a company
called aveer so what year does is they
provide the virtual appliance the year
VF XT that can run in the Google compute
instance and the customer that has data
on Prem in an ass or an object storage
you can cache that data in the cloud run
your compute in the cloud we that is
obviously very common but we're also
seeing a lot of customers then want to
move that data into Google Cloud storage
or an object storage in the cloud and a
viewer has a physical appliance that
basically is a gateway that can do that
so that's that's essentially cloud
bursting and from the cloud perspective
we also call it reach back to on-premise
right basically reaching back to the
data that's on on-premise alright so
moving forward so back up and back up to
the cloud right so the backup to the
cloud has been around for many many many
years and it's been talked about a lot
yet not all the data is is backed up in
the cloud and they're good reasons for
that
where we are seeing an acceleration on
that and we believe that it's going to
accelerate even more and then there are
several reasons for this number one been
talked in detail about data growth and
then there's just so much data that
needs to be backed up now and you need
limitless amounts of capacity for that
fixed budgets so you have you you're
basically trying to do the backup
without increasing the budgets we're
trying to do more with less right all
the time and then you progressive CIOs
want the IT priorities to be aligned
with with what the company outcomes are
right the company goals are and managing
tape is not super high in priority
always and then obviously security and
compliance even for your secondary
storage data you want your data to be
secure you want it to be compliant and
and cloud provides a way for that and so
if not cloud the other options are
obviously tape and disk and let me just
quickly touch upon those tape is
obviously inexpensive it's very widely
used it's it's used very often for long
term backups but it comes with its own
set of challenges so it is slow it's
it's often stored off-site right I'm
Pete recruiting preaching to the choir
here for sure
but if it is slow eerie restore stored
off-site it can take several hours for
you to restore or several days for you
to restore and then it's manual we had a
customer which had ten plus petabytes of
data that was basically backups that
they had done over the years and they
wanted to know how they can move that to
the cloud the big challenge was based on
the resourcing they had they had done
the math and it would have taken several
months for somebody who just read those
tapes right so it becomes a challenge if
used to manual process and then whenever
you have lots of manual steps
Murphy's Law comes into effect and it's
always error-prone and then disk disk is
less manual right it's it's it's
relatively easier to manage but it is
expensive it is not meant for long-term
durable storage and it doesn't scale
that well so that is why we believe in
backup to the cloud and we obviously
have a vested interest but but we
believe that cloud comes with its
advantages for example reliability has
been said we Google Cloud Storage all
the sewage classes come with 11 lines of
durability so you don't have to worry
about your data losing your data high
availability your your cloud storage
almost
goes down at least for Google and and
and security right so you can encrypt
your data you can manage access control
and you can get all the benefits of what
Google is investing and making
interesting in security and then making
sure we have all the right safeguards in
place but it often comes down to cost
and and we've our customer engineering
team has developed essentially a backup
calculator that can based on your
scenario based on your trade-offs do the
math and then indicate what my whether
or not cloud is a good option because
you have to look at several costs
including upfront capex capital outlay
costs the personal cost recovery cost
and then there are advantages to each
each storage media all right
so how this backup work what is the
deployment architecture and then these
are two of the most common models we've
seen with our customers the first one I
guess you can call it the direct model
you know you're using a backup software
whether it's very test net backup or
something else and you can use the
built-in integrations to backup the data
directly to the cloud and we'll talk
about that in more detail and the other
model is you can essentially use a
storage gateway which which you can you
can point your backup software to and
then you can use that Storage Gateway to
move that data to the cloud and we see
that as a common model as well that's
very helpful if your backup software
doesn't integrate with the cloud for
whatever reason then you can always use
a gateway all right so to talk more
about our using your backup software and
and then the integration let me hand
over the mic to Ralph from veritas who's
and let's hear from the experts
all right can you guys hear me over
there all right
unfortunately I don't have the mic so
you aren't gonna get the data dance that
I had plan on doing today so I apologize
for that
so first of all Ralph when I'm a
principal product manager for net backup
responsible for our cloud vision and
strategy and for when I tell my kids
what I do I said well you know I help
customers use the cloud more efficiently
and so that sometimes I give me that
look and they say okay well I showed
them the presentation that I was doing
for Google they're like oh okay so
you're gonna help Google protect their
data I'm like no I'm gonna help
customers use their data and put their
data in Google so it's made of heavily
available and he goes my youngest he
goes what does that mean as I said well
basically it's like YouTube you can use
YouTube on any device well you're gonna
have your data available across the
world from an enterprise perspective and
he goes okay cool so if he understood
that then hopefully you guys are gonna
understand that as well
and so for us from a Veritas perspective
we we have three distinct use cases that
we always talk about especially when I'm
talking about the cloud there's actually
four but I'm talking about three when
when customers are looking at how do I
really start to utilize the cloud and my
infrastructure we really start off with
with storage and and for us it's all
about how do we give customers the
ability to take a their toe and dip it
in and start to move some of their data
into the cloud and so for us we adopted
cloud connectors for Google to give you
the ability to use both of those cold
and Nearline storage tiers that meant
vendor shared and been shared because
that's really what customers wanted to
really start doing it's easy for them to
adopt and then next thing the question
is okay now that I've got my data up
there well I want to start running some
more workloads well we have the
capability now which was part of the
announcement is that we certified Google
cloud to run that back up so that means
you can go out and pick an instance type
that you want utilize the the evaporator
system that we support from that backup
and easily roll out in that backup
server now of course the next question
is so when is NetBackup going to be in a
launcher well we're working on that
we're actually gonna have that available
here shortly so that you can actually
roll out in that backup
from the marketplace within the matter
of a few minutes and in any region you
want and then number three is how do I
use the cloud or utilize these cloud
gateways to help me you really move that
data up a lot quicker because what I've
heard from customers of all shapes and
sizes is that we have petabytes of data
that we want to move to the cloud but we
don't have the bandwidth to handle it
and so the cloud gateway is a definitely
a great option for those customers
because they can break their streams up
into multiple different segments and
send data up to the cloud and the
frequency that matches their bandwidth
and also their SL A's and so for us this
is really the way that we see you know
working with Google to give you guys
especially if you're looking at how do I
really jump into the cloud these are the
options that are out there now as far as
how how do I really get started with
this the goal for us from that backup
perspective is don't take you out of the
the user experience that you're used to
it you're used to creating backup jobs
inside of that backup you're used to
creating storage devices and if you're
not in that backup customer shame on you
guys it's the best product out there it
rocks
it takes care of everybody's data of
course I have to say that because this
is my product but when we looked at how
do we incorporate cloud storage into
NetBackup it was all about the user
experience and so what you're seeing are
just a couple of examples of you know
from the UI you basically I'm going to
add cloud storage you're gonna find
Google and you're gonna pick your tier
and then from there you're going to
specify your credentials simple as that
we go up to make the connection for you
we're already optimized to send data
based off of the parameters that we work
with Google to not only break up our
data into the right chunks but also the
compression and encryption capabilities
that we know that you guys need for this
type of data and so it's a super easy
configuration most of our customers love
the fact that they don't have to go
outside of that backup to incorporate
Google's cloud storage capabilities and
now with our partnership it's not only
just about data protection but it's also
about giving you the full 360 data
management access to your data so
hopefully you've heard about our 360
data management platform that we're
working to here at Veritas what's the
value that this really brings you
especially from
perspectives you're gonna get that
insight you're not only gonna know
exactly what data do I want to sit into
the cloud versus the data that may not
even be cloud ready or maybe data that
shouldn't be in the cloud such as the
company picnic pitchers from 2016 that
really don't need to be in the cloud so
have that insight to that data and then
be able to have the the capabilities to
use cloud as a dr target those are all
their areas that we're working with with
Google with other products in our
portfolio as well as having the ability
to do copy data management and so that
is all about giving you the true
end-to-end capabilities with data giving
you the insight and be able to move that
data into the cloud tier that you want
being able to use that data for other
analytics that you may have and also use
the cloud as a recovery target so I'll
turn it back over to Megan thanks Ralph
so we were worried about Ralph jumping
around the stage so much so we get we
didn't give him a lapel we give him my
stage CI so the key takeaway here is you
could use the best software's out there
the software's that you already used and
keep you and start backing up to the
cloud another key takeaway is we're
seeing a customer's backup from all
kinds of sources all kinds of
applications and servers to the cloud
another example of a partner a cloud
berry lab they they're their software
allows customers to backup your sequel
your exchange servers your device
endpoints so you have if you have a Mac
or a Windows machine you can pack that
up but you can even backup SAS
applications so G suite or office 365 so
diverse sources here and before I wrap
up and back up one interesting use case
we are seeing is a lot of our customers
are running mission-critical
applications in the cloud often behind
those applications they're running no
sequel a scalable database databases
like Cassandra and [ __ ]
and then we're seeing them use backup
software one of our partners data i/o
they're using using the software to
backup to Google Cloud storage all right
so moving on from back up and let's talk
about tearing or active archiving or
cold hearing to the cloud and as I
mentioned creating tiered storages is
not sort of new that you typically have
a highly performant active storage here
you may have a less active storage tier
that's that's slightly cheaper and then
you may have some archival storage tiers
an online one an offline one and we
believe that the as you go from left to
right in this picture cloud becomes a
very viable option for actively
archiving your data and then but how do
you do it so a couple of ways right you
could either use an on-premise storage
platform that has this functionality
built in my example is cloudian which
provides on-prem object storage and then
they can tear this data to the cloud
based on policies yet at the same time
maintain the metadata on-premise and
provide a global namespace so that's one
way to do it and and there are many many
of our partners have have this
functionality whether using I think EMC
is here in another session if you're
using something like quantum or one of
the other object storage or NASA
platforms tiering is often an inbuilt
functionality but you could also use a
gateway to to do that keyring and let me
talk about comprise which which does
that but more so comprise is an
analytics driven data management
platform that basically in a few minutes
you can get full visibility into all
your on-prem of storage and you can
understand based on policies how much
are why would it would it give you if
you move those data to the cloud and it
can move that data to the cloud without
without disrupting your existing
workflows and and I'm going to hand it
over to Bent but before I do that if
you're interested in comp rise I believe
they're doing a free assessment for
Google customers to understand what kind
of ROI can result in
all right thanks all right so this
conclusion roof
alright so question then is that what
and when to move so you can see the kind
of criteria right to move data to the
cloud data there's older than 30 days so
data that's less frequently used data
there's in like branch offices that you
may want to come move to your own
central data centers now since this data
is re going over the network why not
move that to the cloud secondary copy so
cloud is very popular for secondary
backups right so you would may have a
primary backup somewhere but a lot of
times you want in secondary backups
somewhere else where in a different
location managed by different people so
call it's a very good destination for
that replacement we have talked about
that so depending on the kind of data
take replacement may make a lot of sense
and we one of the things that we didn't
quite mention is like there are
companies whose well secondary value
right they have a primary product but
the secondary value is the IP right so
once you want to protect your IP you
need to access your your archives and
all that on a very frequent basis so
rather than keeping this data in on tape
with Iron Mountain and then you want to
retrieve for discovery you need to pay
them a lot of money and you know there's
a lot of the time why not put all this
data in the cloud was like faster to
access faster pull out faster to get
recovery and then you get really good
value out of the data and that goes to
data with with locked up value also data
supporting what I call business
continuity or data recovery so all of
this data is better in the cloud because
one of the things also right we talked
about replication we do all of that for
you we have had sessions elsewhere where
customers will ask us for oh I need to
worry about where I should store the
data right geographically well guess
what we cannot take care of that for you
you know when you ready choose county
regional regional
that's kind of like implicit as opposed
to like having your IT people like thing
through all that stuff and and worried
that no I'm not replicating my data
currently so when to do all this stuff
is like you know typical catalyst events
right where your equipment is going you
know obsolescence
where you need to do structural upgrades
or where you have a new CIO they say hey
we need to go the cloud first okay
that's a good way to get on cloud goes
backups you know you move to cloud
storage it's safe there's a little risk
and you can always say that hey we are
clout ready right all right so summary
so essentially what we're trying to say
here is that there's a whole ecosystem
of partners to support you guys when you
want to kind of like do this different
scenarios right whether you're doing
best thing backup or tearing and then
what's next for you so talk to your rep
right your Google reps about upcoming
solutions so they're the roadmap in
place that we cannot kind of discuss
about NDA so talk to your reps contact
us for a tape versus cloud calculator so
we talk about pricing day like maybe
that was pointing out try the comprise
free assessment and then importantly go
downstairs visit our partners at the
expo so all of them are there go and
talk to them about how they can help you
guys do hybrid and hearing - cloud
storage
so really this session I think there's a
big large scale data ingest session
tomorrow Friday
that's my session yeah and then if you
guys have missed it was there was an
earlier session that talked about cloud
storage but the content should be
available online I think it's gonna be
on YouTube after this so you guys can
come look at it and dig deeper into
cloud storage what that means for you
and so on
[Music]
you